he is known as the Dutch Donald Trump
not only for his hairstyle but largely
for his Furious rant against immigrants
and
Muslims we will make sure that the
Netherlands will be for Dutch people
again we will restrict the Asylum
tsunami and migration people will have
more money in their wallet again in a
historic vote K wers and his Freedom
Party received more votes than anyone
had predicted putting him in the best
position to lead the new Dutch
government from a controversial
politician who has been found guilty of
inciting discrimination to a possible
prime minister while many here in the
Netherlands are still trying to digest
the surprising outcome of this election
K Wilders is already reaching out to
possible Coalition Partners one party
which may be willing to talk is the
people's party for freedom and democracy
for 13 years the country's largest this
time losing 10 seats in
Parliament I think politicians have big
lessons to learn from this we did not
listen enough to the people and we did
not offer enough workable Solutions we
don't get to take the initiative this
time others in and outside politics have
called Wilders win a disaster for the
Netherlands and for the European Union I
will
immigrate no I will not but uh I'm very
worried winning is one thing forming a
coalition government in the Dutch
fragmented political landscape another
as soon as celebrations are finished
Wilders will embark on this often long
and complicated Journey step fast in Al
jazer the
hake make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer